winter is coming and we could be in for
the perfect storm the chief executive of
the uk health security agency warning
it'll be the first time we're likely to
see flu spreading in any real numbers
circulating alongside covid early
evidence suggesting we're twice as
likely to die from having the two
together than just covid alone we do
know that flu
cases have been lower in the previous
years so immunity and the strain types
are a little more uncertain the
difference here is because we have if
you like skipped a year almost with
with flu
it's possible we might see multi-strain
flu
experts say england could see a surge in
covert cases because of how long it's
taking to inoculate children just 11 of
12 to 15 year olds have had a
coronavirus vaccine compared to a third
in scotland with fears the combination
of flu and covert 19 could make for
what's being called a twin endemic the
real concern is as the weather
deteriorates as the viruses perhaps
another wave of coded and a wave of flu
and a weighted wave of rsv that could
end up with the hospitals
under enormous pressure and that would
be a great concern the vaccination and
infection control measures are so
important to keep the pressure off
and at the level of individuals never
mind pressure on the nhs if an
individual particularly if they're
vulnerable were to get
flu and covered at the same time that
would be very serious
pre-covid some might have dismissed the
need for getting a flu vaccine but this
year it's hoped the message is getting
through
there has certainly been a surge in
demand especially since the nhs launched
this annual flu vaccination campaign
earlier on this week
this friday alone we had a
request for more than 300 appointments
per minute on our booking platforms
with the growing threat of a winter
crisis there is added incentive to get
as many people as possible vaccinated to
save lives and to try to stop the nhs
from being overwhelmed
there you are well done katie spencer's
sky news